this video is sponsored by babyon better help
more on them after the reaction people what up
citizens of the reject Nation we are here to
watch the Grand Theft auto6 official trailer
I've been at Carmax for like the last 6 hours
this came out right when I arrived at Carmax
but it allowed me the opportunity to talk with
some people on social media because I only play
Grand Theft Auto 3 Vice City and San Andreas
so there's a couple that I missed oh I played
those and I played four oh congratulations but
people said no we should still check out the
trailer cuz it's been like a decade or a while
you're at the car dealership try to legally
anyway guys let's see what's going on in this
trailer and what all the hype's about because
people are talking about it primarily because
it's been like a very very long time but let's
see who Lucia Luc bad luck I guess woke Theft Auto
are we back in Florida are we back in uh
in Vice yeah I think we are it looks like
a swap damn look at the beach the character
model sir yeah I mean that looks like La holy
moly I think we're going everywhere it
was definitely now this looks like just
Vice ooh it is vice okay Tik tok's reals
one of those look a little San Andreas
but Florida yeah Florida man guys watering it is
underwear look who's back gr Theft Auto's back
em whoa whoa dirt dir bike dirt bags so the main
characters a couple trust dang okay you what you
choose which one you want to be the Vice that's
pretty exciting is exciting yeah no definitely
oh wow I need to pick it back up man I got some
thoughts let's hear them all right after a word
from our sponsor hello there esteem viewer of the
real rejects hi Greg Alba language connoisseur and
world gentlemen I'm here to bestow upon you the
secrets of Babel the language app that transforms
mere mortals into linguistic gods in just 3 weeks
why Babel you inquire my dear friends in this age
of monolingual mundanity mundanity mity mundanity
Babel is our Beacon of Hope crafted by an army of
over 150 language experts their lessons are
like linguistic caviar Rich refined and oh
so satisfying personal tale of Triumph I once
whispered sweet nothings in Spanish or for the
lame in espanol to my wife courtesy of Babel
her reaction was well I'll tell you she was
utterly Bewitched Greg you silver tongue devil no
paraphrasing she exclaimed such vocabulary as I
bass in the glory of my perfect pronunciation as
Babel isn't just about learning words it's about
embracing the art of conversation with podcasts
live classes and a veritable smorgus sport of
interactive lessons I know the words I'm saying
and their speech recognition it's like having a
personal language Butler ensuring every syllable
is impeccably Cris that breaks yourselves for an
offer of monumental proportions here's a
special limited time deal for our viewers
and listeners to get you started right now get
55% off your Babel subscription but again only
for our viewers at babel.com rejects 55% off at
babel.com rejects spelled b a BB l.com rejects
rules and restrictions May apply join me the Greg
Alin the adventure of language Mastery at Babel we
shall not just learn no nay we shall conquer
the world of communication or as they say in
Spanish we're done with this ad all righty time
to get a little bit serious so around the holiday
season we often focus on getting gifts for
others but it's also important to consider
the gifts that we give to ourselves personally I
found that maintaining mental health balance is a
continuous Journey cuz like I've mentioned before
I've been diagnosed with type 2 bipolar ADHD and
PTSD and in a lot of ways I've also grown up in
the last few years on camera with you guys and
therapy has been a crucial part of my life before
the channel even and like many of you my anxiety
and depression seems to magnify this time of
year still don't quite understand the winter
Blues but it does however does help me navigate
the ups and downs and stay grounded for the most
part and while I have my own approach to therapy
I understand everyone's path is unique and that's
why we are proud to be sponsored by betterhelp
this week it's an online platform that makes
therapy accessible and tailored to your needs and
I know a few people who have discovered therapy
via betterhelp and it has been transformative
you start with a questionnaire that helps match
you with a licensed therapist and the best part
and an important part you can switch therapist
anytime ensuring the right fit for you better
help is all about convenience and flexibility
it fits into your schedule and it's all online
so whether you're looking to start therapy for
the first time or continue your journey better
help can be a great option so in the season of
giving remember to give yourself what you need
too with better help take that step towards your
better self so you can visit betterhelp.com
rejects for 10% off your first month that's
better hp.com rejects take care and stay healthy
reject Nation happy holidays we're starting off
we seeing this Lucia girl and I feel like this
would probably be the start of the game right
like it starts off where she is uh you're being
pared being paroled but then she's immediately
going to go back to the life she knows Life
Of Crime with her hot boyfriend and I could
see my immediately that ending shot made me go uh
I could see myself getting invested into it like
a modern day Bonnie and Clyde sort of a situation
totally these thieves well gangsters criminals but
you know I I naturally just going to be very
drawn and connected to oh there are a couple
and I can get Bard with it one of them has to die
they do but before that happens there's got to be
like a couple's mode you can play in where like
you and your partner you know can choose one of
the players and then like you know ruin your own
relationship through the game you your own bad
decision making of the game but what's cool about
this is it's all like cinematic Graphics but it's
Grand Theft Auto so you know that you're going to
be able to partake in a lot of what we're seeing
on screen like debauchery in the debauchery like
you're looking at the speedboats you're looking
at Yachts that people on the beach you imagine
you're going to be able to go into I want to
see that beach shot again because the city looks
so huge oh yeah this is this is massive yeah and
so much of the charm of all these games is just
how open the open world is and just getting to
explore and and yeah cause havoc in every kind of
environment want a mud booat it's going to be fun
to this like fan boat it's going to be fun to
ride around on that thing oh yeah that's what
I love about this because it's all cinematics but
you know you're going to be able to actually use
everything that you're seeing here on screen your
crime Stars up stealing someone fan po but this
the amount of this is going to sound strange but
I think Grand Theft Auto players will know what
I'm talking about the amount of bodies that are
yes absolutely cuz you get a mess with all of
them you can interact with them all you might
even be able to form meaningful relationships
with someone that's what we're all Hing for
but like the amount of bodies there are the
amount of different types of bodies that there
are as well it feels like you're on an actual
beach somewhere it the the model designs here are
insane look at this dude this muscled out guy I
know I know and then this other guy with like a
bandana on his head just drifting into the water
elar oh my God this that these couple shots made
me feel like oh maybe we're back in San Andreas
but n this is this is all it's just a City night
life with the crazy cool gangster day life that
we know that's right that that we spend most of
our waking hours in places like this we got out
of prison we said we're going to start a YouTube
channel my God is that where I spend every wake
like every Saturday afternoon you know just like
chilling with my boys I imagine that with these
two guys who we just saw here anyone that were
getting like close-ups on I imagine characters
yeah or people are going to send you on pretty
notable missions yeah or rival gangs oo there's
got to be I hope we get to encounter Dexter Morgan
here yes TV showtime cross is this the first one
to go back to Vice comment in comment down below
look at that water yeah oh my god well that's the
thing too is like there's there's honey there's
always oh my God yes please this has to be the
most screenshotted moment of the entire trailer
yeah don't put any of the notable characters just
this girl posing at this trailer have a Michael
Bay movie right here yeah well that's the thing
is like there's always like this sort of like
a c no matter how good the graphics get and I
don't mean this as a slight there's always
like something a little bit Whimsical about
the animation of a Grand Theft Auto game and so
to see these people looking so photo and to see
so many like you know bikini beach babes and
stuff like that and and like you know tanning
oil dudes it's it's fun and fascinating because
again this is like as beautiful and photoreal
as this has ever looked and yet it still hasn't
lost that unique kind of cheeky Grand Theft Auto
cartoon quality I completely agree with every
sentiment you have here John and this right
here has got to be a Leonard DiCaprio over Jack
Nicholson Wolves of Wall Street baby right here
hanging out with everyone oh this is that same
girl who we just saw closeup on I'm going to
commit her to memory if you squint long enough
you can see past the animation stuff maybe the
animation thing is the thing you guys are into
too yeah totally hey there's going to be a lot
of messing with alligators in this yes I want to
kill I want to rack up a body count only based
on alligators alone I love twerking on the top
you got to get it Ghost Ride the Whip it's like
the it's like what Lizzie McGuire looks like now
let let her live at the gas station don't be out
here creeping with your phone it's I love how
they're like playing on uh Tik toks and reals
Yeah well yeah cuz like you're causing the kind
of people would yeah you're causing the kind of
havoc and also living the kind of you know glit
see wildlife that I guess a lot of people on Tik
Tok and the like would want to live or at least
showcase themselves living I love this yes yeah
and I'm like is this reminisence of a real shot
we'll see in the game based on some action you had
control over or is this like a random moment for
the trailer body cams okay these are cops going
in here yeah oh my god do you get to play as cops
ever you get to play I think I don't know there's
a couple of games I have totally missed so I'm
not sure but yeah I feel like five would be a
good Touchstone to go back for in terms of what
modern modern GTA has become look at that look
at that com yeah see I love that this trailer
lot of details in this trailer when you slowing
down yeah no it's beautiful and like what's great
is this trailer pulls you in with the stuff you
remember from Vice City of like oh yeah we're at
the beach and it's glamorous and it's Miami life
and then we slowly descend into like Florida man
chaos by the end of the trailer which I'm sure
was always there but yeah like it takes a marked
turn here look at these Biden supporters that's
right man keep America Joe keep America Brandon
oh she's got to be hat she's got to be a returning
character look who's back that's right that's
the line that she has it cures emotions oh my
God what is that a play on John Ang Stan America's
favorite F does it say it back America's favorite
disassociative is that medication Yeah well yeah
I mean it's definely play on vid yeah no but yeah
I think it's some kind of like was a play on
The Rona but it looks like it's a plan like an
anti-anxiety measure yeah it's like a pH I think
it says America's favorite dissoc dissociative
so yeah it's like it must help you just Divorce
Yourself from all reality oh no overturn weasel
news uh oh and jaral letto Joker imp meets the
guy the yeah definitely Suicide Squad maybe
that's what we needed maybe he's like the main
one of the main villains I don't know could be
I got the imagery like and the way they're so
good at like recreating news footage and stuff
like that in these games dirt bike dirt B dirt
bags weasel news they're just misunderstood oh
yeah this is a cool couple to look at man yeah
this is so cool looking I got to say and it has
that like Natural Born Killers like even though
you're not really Natural Born Killer is more rap
than Bonnie and Clyde sure and you're spending a
whole lot of time on like the main characters they
don't look like murderers they look like robers
like they're like maybe they don't want to kill
they just have to kill they look like people
who were only doing this until they could get
out you know yeah for sure yeah misunderstood
that's the Hope anyway you know because people
are always playing these games with an eye for
the morality I imagine they have a kid or some
[__] she's got to have a bigger cause than
just getting back in right I feel like that'll
probably be it yeah no they're going to take us
on a harrowing emotional Journey probably get you
emotionally involved by going oh she's got a kid
yeah and she's doing crimes we got to protect our
belly and someone coms like why does she have to
have a kid cuz she's a woman yes that's why yeah
yes that's why they're like putting a woman
the lead of our game we're required to have
her a baby got to have a woman we got to have a
woman baby a woman baby woman with a baby woman
with a baby all righty guys what you think about
the Grand Theft TR live to the hype leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like and um I I I am in the process of over
the next year trying to figure out how to do live
stream Let's Plays but oh I don't know I've never
done it before so I have to figure it out but I
will leave it to me go ahead John do it see you
guys